hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
over the last 11 or 12 years
i've been working ridiculously hard to
become successful i am now
a multi-millionaire i'm 29 years old and
in this video
i'm gonna give you seriously the exact
four steps that you need to become
successful you might think
oh the four steps but this really is
exactly what i have personally done from
a working-class background
up to becoming a multi-millionaire has
it all been easy no
has it been fun yes have i succeeded yes
and this is what you need to do you do
this honestly
you're gonna be successful it's gonna be
inevitable first thing you need to do to
succeed i'm kind of joking but this
would help me out
is smash the like button smash the like
button
honestly destroy it i need you to hammer
that like button
if you are watching this video and the
the thumb is not blue
there's a serious problem make the thumb
make it blue okay here are the four
things also
if you're not subscribed to my channel i
put out a video every single day
every single day i don't know anyone
else that does this who's successful who
shares their tips every day
so please do subscribe turn the
notification bell on so you don't miss a
video so
four things number one you need action
you gotta take action so many people
just listen and think and watch and
wonder and ponder
and they never actually do anything if
you wanna be successful you have to take
massive
massive action implementation
is the key to success two types of
people
there's generally people that observe
and then there's people that participate
if you want to succeed you often you
know what you need to do
you want to be slim eat less exercise
more
what's going to make you actually be
able to do it the difference is going to
be those people that actually
do it get off the sofa take action
they're the people that are going to win
and the same in anything the same
certainly in business you want to become
successful
you've got to do what you know you need
to do you've got to take massive action
that's step one
step two is you've got to get the
knowledge so that the things that you're
acting upon
are the right type of things so you've
got to get educated you don't have to
spend
tens of thousands of pounds on expensive
training courses to do this i run
training courses
some of them are a pound some of them
are thousands of pounds
but you've got to just get the knowledge
so my advice would be read
books attend seminars talk to people
that are successful so you can get a
right roadmap
and then once you've got the knowledge
what are you going to do you're going to
take action on it
if you learn something and you don't
take action on it you lose it
if you don't use it you lose it so you
need to be continually
learning applying getting knowledge
getting trained
taking action two together you're gonna
fly i am
so thankful to my mentors trainers and
advisors
that have helped me in my business
because instead of learning from my own
mistakes
i've learned from their mistakes which
has meant that i became a millionaire a
lot quicker than if i'd just kept making
mistakes again and again and again
some people say oh but training and
education is really expensive
and the answer is it doesn't have to be
you can start by just reading books
you can get audible which is about 10
pounds a month and you can listen to as
many books as you want
but if you think education is expensive
then you should try
ignorance that is going to kill you in
business so you need to be continually
learning
i teach property investment you can come
on a program if you want but property
is the second best investment the best
is yourself
your knowledge your brain that's your
best asset so they're the first two
things
what's next number three is you need to
believe
that you can do it now this sounds hocus
pocus but it's so
true so you're going to be learning
you're going to be taking
action but you've got to be believing in
yourself
if you believe that it's not going to
happen it's probably not going to happen
if you believe that it's going to happen
and you take action and you take the
right kind of action because you have
the right knowledge
it's going to happen you've got to
believe in yourself you've got to
believe in the systems you've got to
believe in your mentors don't walk
around life
being skeptical all the time it's good
to it's good to be cautious
but not too cautious that you don't ever
do anything you've got to believe it's
going to happen
and i usually think this i think if
someone's done it
i can do it no one's better than me i'm
not better than anyone
but if it's possible i believe i can do
it that's the kind of courage
and belief that you need when you're
taking action and you're taking the
right kind of action
last thing number four you need to
persist
believe me this is a marathon not a
sprint
yes you can get results very very fast
sometimes but don't be in this
for the short term be in this for the
long term it's amazing what can happen
if you give it a year or two if you give
up after the first few days
you're never going to be successful
you've got to persist the going's going
to get tough
people see me be successful see my house
see my car i think oh my gosh she's 29
what they don't see is the scars and
stab wounds in my back from all the
people that have stabbed me in the back
from all the rejection i've received
from the friends that have betrayed me
from people that have lied to me and let
me down
believe me at times i felt like quitting
but because i just kept going
because i kept persisting that's why i
get to live the life that i live with my
family
with my on my vacations that i go on and
it's a good life but it wasn't easy
neither will it be for you so get the
knowledge
take massive action believe you can do
it and if you don't believe you can do
it let me believe
on your behalf that you can do it and be
ready to persist because it's going to
get tough
but believe me you do those four things
you're gonna get there thanks for
watching the video
don't forget to comment don't forget to
smash the like button if you haven't
already
and don't forget to subscribe turn the
notification bell on
and i'll see you next time